diavel scholars this is when mister
papers the framework such an ipad air 2 red
wine total bad-en eaj that not only
place video games wheelie
it can if there are three size 0 and 10
scenarios and more this is an
interesting new framework that
contains envision  model with compressions
what that can be seen in the game
into an internal colt is here see here
who is leed and variable sar responsible
to capture the ground level designs
and keep this variable simulation time and
choice firewalls move the world
has over time this is a highly
compressed internal representation
that captures the most important aspects
of the game to your heaven memory unit
the nature historical previous
experience is with similarly already an
earlier work products the next en
strokes of dehydration
this can also agree again gameplay
family
it is also and builds must  the controller
je just that is responsible for making
decisions as to how to play the game
here your cd arboretum in action on the
left this the a  ctual gameplay en dan de
right you see slightly compressed internal
representation this is how do you think
about the game the point is that it is
unloading
there for some information is last met
the essence of the game is weekend
this will sounds great the novelty is clear  with
hou sit there play the
game in this racing game on a selection
of 100 random tracks something and rode score
is ours free times dat of deep mind
grime breaking the pure learning garrett
him this was the one you de to the world
by storm  from deep mind emmen street this
love it learn to play it harry break
out and many other games of the
superhuman level
this is almost three times better than
that education pull a do it is to be
noted that it might and social media
contest since the regional  die glenn
work and now comes the even more
exciting part because it can enter an
internal li-ion representation of the
game and this representation really
captures the essence of the game damn it
means that this is if  o able to play and
training
when big dreams and century it makes a
dream scenarios and learns how to deal
with them how old claim the action game
it is a bit like how you prepare for
the first date in margin and what to say
and how to  say the ear
imogen coworking capacity and the
chord we darkride chops
if some one word trip dachshunds and the cool
zinga is that we signal this dream
training actually works which means that
the newly land 3 en strategies translate'
wheelie water the real game
we will  i have only scratch the surface
to make sure to widen peper in the
description
this is a wheelie new and fresh idea
and i think it will give birth to number
of aloha peper
cannot wait to report on the back to you
to stay tuned and make sure  to subscribe
and pour the ball icon to never miss an
episode 5 searching for your generous
support na see you next time